traiter les problèmes du Sahel c'est
traiter par prévention la sécurité en
Europe
une partie de la population au Sahel
exprime de plus en plus le rejet de la
présence française y a-t-il eu une
évolution du sentiment anti-français en
Afrique oui il y a eu tout à fait une
évolution j'étais au Mali au début des
années 2000 jusqu'à 2006 j'y retourne
chaque année j'ai pu voir l'évolution
mais à l'époque où j'y étais les
relations étaient extrêmement positives
entre la France et le Mali et les autres
pays du Sahel Burkina aussi pendant des
décennies ce problème n'a pas été
visible parce que on espérait peut-être
à la fois en France et dans le Sahel que
l'aide au développement allait avoir des
effets positifs il a fallu un certain
temps pour se rendre compte que ça ne
fonctionnait pas combiné avec
l'explosion démographique et la jeunesse
qui n'a pas d'emploi et pas de
perspective et l'insécurité se
développer à partir de 2015
essentiellement et c'est cette
impuissance à régler ce problème qui a
été le facteur décisif disons la goutte
d'eau qui a fait un peu déborder le
sentiment anti français qui est
responsable de cette situation la faute
est partagée entre la France et les pays
ça il y a il est évident qu'il y a eu
une succession d'erreurs françaises
d'abord il fallait être moins visible
parce que forcément on allait être
suspecté de néocolonialisme donc moins
visible avec la monnaie par exemple le
français phare avec les bases militaires
avec les interventions militaires de
gendarmes de l'Afrique avec aussi les
discours comminatoires on donne des
injonctions sur ce qu'il faut faire etc
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a
sous-estimé la gravité de la situation
du Sahel et on a saupoudré une petite
aide au développement de l'ordre de 3%
de la totale française on a préféré
s'occuper des pays émergents où la LED
au développement semblait plus efficace
et plus facile et la troisième chose
c'est que sur le plan militaire on a
fait quand même une série d'erreurs la
présence militaire française sous la
forme de barkades qui a succédé à Serval
a été beaucoup trop longue n'est-ce pas
nous sommes restés 9 ans au Mali nous
sommes encore présents dans les autres
pays du Sahel essentiellement le Burkina
le Tchad et le Niger c'est trop long
pour une armée de l'ancienne puissance
coloniale il aurait fallu être en appui
seulement des armées locales on est
apparu au contraire comme ce battant à
part de façon séparée on a donné le
sentiment de marginaliser les armées
locales et de ne pas respecter
finalement la souveraineté de ces pays
ce qui nous est beaucoup reproché tout
ceci a été exploité par la Russie ça a
été exploité d'une façon facile il a
suffi d'avoir des activistes locaux
appuyés par les services russes et il a
suffi d'avoir des vidéos fabriquées par
les services russes exploitant le cas
échéant des mensonges pour dire à la
population que en fait l'armée française
n'était pas là pour se battre contre les
djihadistes mais tu es là pour espoer
lors du Bali les richesses du Mali et
même étaient complices des djihadistes
que c'était ça la raison pour laquelle
ça ne fonctionnait pas parce que
soi-disant selon les Russes la France
avait un double jeu et en fait n'était
pas du tout intéressé par la stabilité
du Sahel et les Russes se sont présentés
à l'inverse comme une puissance non
coloniale alors pourquoi le fait-elle
c'est pas vraiment pour se substituer à
la France puisqu'elle n'a pas les moyens
d'aider véritablement ces pays c'est
plutôt un combat garantie français et
antioxydantal c'est à dire c'est une
revanche de la Russie contre la
politique française en Ukraine ou
vis-à-vis de la Russie essentiellement
et c'est aussi peut-être on peut
imaginer le pire malheureusement dans
l'idée de créer un certain chaos qui
peuvent être les conséquences de cette
perte d'influence de la France en
Afrique les conséquences directes ça
risque d'être l'affaiblissement des pays
concernés lorsqu'un pays comme le Mali
s'isole et rejettent l'influence
européenne française occidentale il
s'affaiblit en réalité parce qu'il se
crée des difficultés économiques il se
créent des difficultés militaires donc
tout ceci fait le jeu des terroristes
des djihadistes à terme la menace c'est
que cette zone se transforme en zone de
chaos d'anarchie et que ça suscite du
terrorisme vers l'Europe des flux
migratoires vers l'Europe on voit quand
même des milliers de subsahariens qui
essayent d'arriver en Europe chaque
année donc on voit déjà le début d'un
phénomène migratoire préoccupant on peut
craindre que le même problème venant du
Moyen-Orient se reproduisent venant
d'Afrique parce que maintenant
l'essentiel des attentats terroristes un
peu plus de la moitié a lieu dans la
région sahélienne qui est devenu
vraiment le relais du terrorisme
international
[Musique]